What is the dumbest
and most physically dangerous
thing you've ever done?
Okay, I know exactly what it is.
There's actually, there's a couple because
I mean, there's more than one.
When I get thinking
about what might be funny
or in front of people,
my good sense tends to go away.
So on tour in I think 2010,
we did this very raucous show
that we toured around the country
and it was in large venues
and I would do all kinds of comedy,
but I would also play the
guitar and do musical numbers.
And it just started to,
the crowds were getting bigger and bigger
and it was turning into,
it was so chaotic
and there was so much energy,
that I remembered one time I ran up,
I had pretty much a
radio mic on my guitar,
so I could go anywhere with the guitar
and I ran up with my guitar
to the second balcony
and I stood on the edge of
the balcony playing the guitar
and didn't even think about it.
And the people who I employ
were furious with me.
They were watching it and
they were like, you asshole,
you were standing there not even looking
at what you were doing and you
so easily could have fallen
and it was, you know, a 30 foot fall.
It wouldn't have gone well.
That was super stupid
and I was very apologetic and,
but I was living out some weird,
hey, look at me, I'm Eddie
Van Halen guitar fantasy
and it was just stupid.
The second one, we were
doing a rehearsal once
with animals and there was
a very large water buffalo
I think from Africa
and someone just said,
hey it might be funny if you got on it.
And the trainer who
actually knew nothing about,
who was just there to hold the animals
and didn't know that much
about each particular one
she said, yeah, get on it.
And I said, okay.
And I later looked back at
the footage 'cause we were
shooting it for rehearsal
and I just said, you probably
remember this too, Sona.
And so I went, yeah okay
and I jumped on the
back of a water buffalo.
Now let me be clear,
a water buffalo, this water buffalo
was the size of a mid-size compact car.
And I jumped on the back of it
and this water buffalo
didn't want me on its back.
So the first thing it did
Wonder why.
was threw me off and I landed
on a solid concrete
floor that's extra dense
so that you can roll TV cameras on it
and I bounced off my left hip
and the buffalo charged forward,
knocked a bunch of cameras over,
then turned around and I,
all I saw was the whites of its eyes
and started charging at me.
And I ran like a cartoon character
and like made a hole in the wall
that was in the shape of my body.
I got a massive hematoma,
it was so big, I couldn't
get my pants off.
And I was like,
thinking back to it when
we looked at the tape,
my sidekick, Andy Richter's standing there
and, or sitting there
and he's not really paying attention
and in fact nobody's paying attention.
But what you can hear is someone says,
I think a segment producer
says, why don't you get on?
What if you got on it?
And then the trainer
goes, yeah, get on it.
I say, yeah, I'll get on it.
And then you hear Andy Richter
say, I wouldn't do that.
(laughing)
And he says it at about that level.
He goes and he, I think he's like
playing with his phone at the same time.
He goes, I wouldn't do that.
So just putting
it on record.
Yeah.
Not trying to really stop you.
He just, he wasn't,
yeah, exactly.
Just, he just says,
eh, I wouldn't do that.
And then you just see me--
He still wanted to see what would happen.
Yeah and then I instantly jump on the,
I don't listen to him.
I jump on the back of the water buffalo
and it's all like my sympathy
is... the water buffalo is right.
It was in the right,
I was in the wrong.
And so, yeah and I think if
I thought about it I can
think of 600 more of those.
I just
(laughing)
and I have nobody to blame, but myself,
but I never said I was the smartest guy.
I'm just--
Never thought it.
Yeah,
oh okay.
All right.
(laughing)
All right, Lux.
Lux et veritas.
Lux,
Lux I'm gonna come to London.
I get there sometimes and
I'm gonna find you, man.
Okay.
And we're gonna settle
this once and for all.
Oh yeah, all right.
Which means that you're going to
with your upper body strength
instantly beat the crap out of me.
To be fair, Conan, I'm quite a short guy.
So you could--
I don't think I,
no, my height is of no advantage,
trust me, the way I use it.